das sind sie die männer des jahres mit
dabei der dänische bösewicht mads
mikkelsen sein deutscher
schauspielkollege daniel brühl und der
tiger tom jones und hoppla hendrik
berlin
euromax reporter aber leider nicht mann
des jahres
ja warum eigentlich etwas fehlt mir um
mann des jahres zu werden
dafür mache ich mich hier in der
komischen oper berlin auf die suche nach
der jury die redaktion des
männermagazins kiku
wir wollen die männer des jahres einmal
im jahr feiern die was natürlich was
ganz besonderes geschafft haben in
diesem jahr aber die auch generell in
ihrem werk und mit ihrer arbeit für was
stehen für haltung und für stil jeweils
in ihrer kategorie der mann 2015
alphatier
oder netter junge jeder dritte mann ist
laut einer umfrage unsicher wir
auftreten soll
mit rad oder mit muskeln
fest steht wir männer haben eine
identitätskrise und scheinen reif für
die couch beim psychoanalytiker
zeit also mal nachzufragen wie sollte
der mann heutzutage seien es netto ein
klug natürlich zuverlässig
charakterstark würde ich sorgen
elegant sollte er sein treu humor haben
tiefgründig französisch würde man die
hand sagen
einfühlsam und selbstsicher und viel
geld verdienen
richtiger mann und wie ich den in mir
entdecken kann zeigt mit john aigner
seit acht jahren ist der personal coach
für männer
seine methode gespräche und übungen vor
dem spiegel
dabei ist das entsprechende männerbild
er 23 es hat sehr sehr viel damit zu tun
als man bei dir zu sein
zu dir zu stehen selbstbewusstsein zu
haben mut zu haben
ein bisschen sinn für freiheit zu haben
ein bisschen sinn für was wildes
rauswollen abenteuer
solche geschichten
john lässt mich verschiedene
körperhaltungen vor dem spiegel ein
seine theorie die pose beeinflusst das
selbstbild körpersprache geht nach außen
und nach innen und dass das geile
deshalb kannst du sie nutzen und
vielleicht ein bisschen breitbeinige
noch und die hände würde ich noch auf
dem roseby entsteht dann
körpersprachlich ein anderer mann
es hat ein bisschen was so von seiner
rüstung aus genau und das entscheidende
dabei ist du spürst dass auch das heißt
keine körpersprache geht auch nach innen
hin da habe ich das gefühl dass ich mal
ein bisschen ernster gucken
probiert es aus
zurück auf dem roten teppich bei der
chikyu gala männer des jahres
jetzt gebe ich mal aus ob das auf dem
roten teppich funktioniert
die frage ist neben die fotografen und
kamerateams notiz von mir können sie
sich vorstellen dass ich auch zu den
männern des jahres gehören
es war ganz lustig jetzt hier bin runter
mitzulaufen und zusehen dass wir dann
doch fotografen gar nicht wirklich
wahrgenommen haben obwohl ich mit
breiter brust und selbstbewusstsein hier
rüber gelaufen bin aber gegen tom jones
hat sich halt dann doch keine chance
vielleicht sollte ich mir rat von denen
holen die es wissen müssen
mann des jahres wie ich werden willst
musst du singen aber ich kann etwas
anderes machen in erster linie musst du
dir selbst treu sein
du musst an dich glauben
selbstbewusstsein ist sehr wichtig wenn
du selbst bewusst ist zeigt sich dass
auch ich bin immer wichtig wenn männer
sich nicht so wichtig nehmen und auch
nicht ihre männlichkeit ständig oder
beweis stellen müssen
er sollte sehr zärtlich zu frauen seien
sehr nett zu den frauen
nicht alle sind nett zu frauen sind sie
es klar das sieht auch gut aus
smoking die fliege sitzt einigermaßen
gerade das ist schon mal ein guter
anfang ja man sollte nicht zu viel auf
andere hören wie sollten wir selbst sein
letztendlich sollte das doch genügen ein
mann sollte ein gentleman sein
er sollte hart arbeiten und
leidenschaftlich sein er sollte aber
auch ein mann sein der gegen kann
der mann 2015 so lange er sich selbst
treu bleibt und das nötige
selbstbewusstsein zeigt hat doch er das
zeug zum mann des jahres